[موسيقى]
ارتبطت مصالح وما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه مع مصالح الولايات المتحده
ومن وراءها دول الغرب عندما شن الغرب حمله
عسكريه على تنظيم الدوله في معركه عين
العرب كوباني الشماليه سوريه في سبتمبر
عام 2014
تاسست بمسمى قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه عام
2015 كانت تحالفا لمقاتلين من مختلف
الاعراف لكن وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
كانت حجر الاساسي والاكثر سيطره على
التنظيم كانت تلك نقطه البدايه لدعم عسكري
ومالي قدمته واشنطن لما تعرف بقوه سوريا
الديمقراطيه بينما قدمت لها فرنسا
وبريطانيا دعما بقوتهما الخاصه لمسانده
عمليات هذه المجموعه على الارض
لاحقا استمر الدعم الامريكي لما تعرف بقوه
سوريا الديمقراطيه في معتبره الحالي سالم
مكافحه للارهاب في مناطق اخرى من سوريا
دير الزور والحسكه وكا جزء من هذه الحمله
اعتقلت ما تعرف القوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
الاف من نقط بتنظيم الدوله من الاجانب
وعائلاتهم ومنهم من قدموا من دول
الاوروبيه
احتدم اثر ذلك جدلا كبير بشان مصيره هؤلاء
المعتقلين فقد رفض الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي
عوده مقاتلي تنظيم الدوله الى بلدانهم
الاوروبيه فاقترحت ما تعرف بقوه سوريا
الديمقراطيه تاسيس محكمه دوليه في سوريا
وتقديمهم اليها ما تبحث عنهما تعرف بقوه
سوريا الديمقراطيه هو اعتراف دولي بدورها
يعزز ادارتها الذاتيه للمنطقه التي تسيطر
عليها في شمال شرق سوريا ولا يتحقق لها
ذلك حتى الان في الاتحاد الاوروبي والامم
المتحده لا يواجهان دعوه للذراع السياسي
لما تعرف بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه من اجل
المشاركه في اي محادثات سياسيه بشان
الازمه السوريه ولا يعترفان الا بالمعارضه
السوريه التي تتخذ مقر لها في اسطنبول
عمليه
بليه جديده في الشمال السوري تعول ما تعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه على الحليف
الامريكي الذي يبقى الراعي الرسمي لها
خارجيا لكنها تحتفظ ايضا بقنوات تواصل مع
روسيا فاولويتها دائما هي ان تحتفظ
باداراتها المستقله للمناطق التي تسيطر
عليها ولا تضطر للتنازل عنها لا للنظام
السوري ولا لتركيا في حال وقوع لعمليه
البريه العسكريه
[موسيقى]